bitte heute der neue präsident
voraussichtlich eigentlich für sie und
das ganze auswärtige haben auch das
kanzleramt ein bisschen weniger arbeit
weil der hat uns der extrem gefordert
der donald trump hat sie extrem
gefordert in den vergangenen vier jahren
jetzt wird er vermutlich ein bisschen
ruhiger vielleicht doch für sie ich
glaube dass das gegenteil der fall sein
wird die werden uns echt viel arbeit
machen und zwar mehr als wenn der
vergangenheit gehabt haben denn in der
vergangenheit gab es auch nicht so viel
konsultationen mit den kolleginnen in
den kollegen in washington die haben
alles selber gemacht und wir haben sie
aus der presse erfahren sind dann ans
telefon gegangen wo man sich anrufen
also das kann ich sagen kann auch nicht
sagen dass ich persönlich gegenüber
meinen kollegen mike p oder irgendwie
ein persönliches problem gehabt hätte
persönlich habe ich ihn sehr geschätzt
und tue das jetzt auch aber die haben
halt politik gemacht die sie nicht mit
anderen abgestimmt haben das wird anders
werden und die werden auch ein paar
erwartungen herunter haben also das wird
jetzt nicht weniger sondern es wird
deutlich mehr aus dem die erwartung was
will joe biden wird was wollen die usa
von deutschland kann man sich da
wirklich auf was du was zölle und so
weiter angeht zurücklehnen oder glauben
sie auch da kommt forderungen wieder auf
europa
naja darüber werden wir mit den neuen
kolleginnen und kollegen reden müssen
aber ich glaube donald trump hat europa
in einem alten suchen mit russland und
china als die gegner der vereinigten
staaten erklärt er hat gegen europa
strafzölle verhängt und liebesbriefe mit
kim jong aus nordkorea ausgetauscht also
das wird alles jetzt ein ende haben
es wird nicht so sein dass sich jetzt
alles in wohlgefallen auflöste die
werden erwartungen an uns haben auch in
außen und sicherheitspolitischen fragen
dass wir auch in unserem mittelbaren
nachbarschaft etwa in afrika im nahen
und mittleren osten in osteuropa mehr
verantwortung übernehmen auch innerhalb
der nato darauf müssen wir glaube ich
gefasst sein und deshalb sprechen wir da
auch schon sehr sehr intensiv im kreis
mit den kolleginnen kollegen etwa in der
europäischen union darüber was sind
eigentlich unsere angebote die wir den
vereinigten staaten machen können das
ist vorbei ist wo man gesehen hat donald
trump ist weggeflogen dürfen wir ein
bisschen mehr auspacken was war denn das
schlimmste was sie da an konfrontationen
erlebt haben wenn sie sagen das war
schon sehr sehr ungewöhnlich was man da
den letzten drei jahren vier jahren
erlebt hat
also erstmal
natürlich ich bin auch froh dass er weg
ist
aber ich habe auch mal dazu sagen weil
ich bin auch mal gefragt worden naja
aber die ganze zeit der der dabei habt
ja irgendwie gut mit ihm
zusammengearbeitet ja das gehört auch
dazu
ob das ergebnis einer demokratischen
wahl und das ist auch bei der wahl von
donald trump gewesen uns gefällt oder
nicht spielt keine rolle sondern wir
müssen mit denjenigen die gewählt sind
versuchen so gut wie möglich zusammen zu
haben das haben wir immer getan trotzdem
für uns auch freuen wenn wir sehen auch
aufgrund dessen was die neuen jetzt
schon gesagt haben das ding ganz anderen
bezug zu europa haben und auch dass
deutschland nicht mehr der prügelknabe
der vereinigten staaten oder im weißen
haus sein wird also insofern gehen wir
da wirklich ganz frohgemut ran und
wollen uns auch er sehr gern mal mit dem
auseinandersetzen was wir die letzten
vier jahre ertragen mussten und das
gibt's doch nicht moment ist es nicht so
hinten mit den mit ihren kollegen aus
dem auswärtigen amt das man da irgendwas
im vorfeld der besucher erfahren hat
oder drum herum wo man denkt also ich
wusste ja schon viel aber das gibt es
nicht also ich würde mal sagen wenn ich
jetzt anfange dazu erzählen reicht die
sendezeit
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren